[Música]
hola bienvenidos a revista digital donde
abordamos los temas más importantes del
ciberespacio y las redes sociales y los
medios de comunicación de américa latina
y el mundo un nuevo capítulo en la
batalla contra los gigantes de internet
48 fiscales de eeuu y la comisión
federal del comercio demandaron a
facebook acusándolo de monopolio agregan
que de manera ilegal ha aplastado su
competencia y buscan que venda dos de
sus más exitosas compañías instagram y
whatsapp porque estas medidas se dan
justo ahora empezamos facebook enfrenta
el caso antimonopolio más grande en
décadas 46 de los 50 estados de eeuu
junto con el distrito de washington y
sigue el territorio de guam presentaron
una demanda en simultáneo con la
comisión federal de comercio señalan a
la compañía de abusar de su poder en el
mercado de las redes sociales para
eliminar a las empresas que desafían su
dominio la situación se centra
específicamente en la adquisición de
whatsapp e instagram dos aplicaciones
que surgieron como independientes y que
ahora hacen parte de su exitoso
portafolio los demandantes buscan que
facebook venda estas dos compañías y con
ellos se restaure la competencia
ya que los usuarios gozan de menos
alternativas de redes sociales a su
disposición durante casi una década
facebook ha utilizado su dominio y poder
monopolístico para aplastar a sus
rivales más pequeños y acabar con la
competencia en un esfuerzo por mantener
su dominio del mercado en las redes
sociales 'facebook' ha empleado una
estrategia de compra agua integral para
impedir los servicios de la competencia
en 2012 facebook compró instagram por un
valor de mil millones de dólares para
entonces la compañía no generaba
ingresos y sólo contaba con 25 millones
de usuarios hoy tiene un promedio de
1000 millones de usuarios activos
mensuales en 2014 se hizo con whatsapp
que costó 19 mil millones de dólares
ambas transacciones fueron aprobadas por
la comisión federal del comercio la
misma que hoy pide que estas compañías
sean vendidas a través de su página web
esta agencia del gobierno dice que más
que las adquisiciones están desafiando
la conducta de facebook de varios años
que a su juicio constituyó la
monopolización del mercado en las redes
sociales porque entonces ahora se
retracta y emprende acciones legales
consultamos a edward ramírez experto en
tecnología el líder de comunidad de
emprendimiento digital en américa
latina'
en estos momentos con respecto a la
situación que se está viendo con el
joven 19 y en general los temas de
pandemia de cuarentena la ciudadanía o
todos los usuarios porque todo en eeuu
se han visto abocados a trabajar desde
las casas todo el tema de teletrabajo lo
que ha disparado por completo una
demanda de servicios a través de
internet y esta demanda pues la vemos en
este momento es acaparada con respecto a
la oferta que tiene facebook el momento
alguien que integra aguantar a instagram
y también está haciendo un esfuerzo
grande para competir contra los demás
actores de videollamadas como web o
google o todos los pequeñitos eso por un
lado y por otro lado el tema de las
redes sociales indiscutiblemente se
volvió una necesidad para que estaban
comunicando el hardware han hecho que
muy pocas empresas puedan competir por
su parte facebook que dice que espera
con ansias su día en la corte recordó a
través de un comunicado que los
reguladores anteriormente dieron luz
verde a estas transacciones porque no
amenazaban la competencia
ahora muchos años después aparentemente
sin tener en cuenta las leyes
establecidas o las consecuencias para la
innovación y la inversión la agencia
dice que se equivocó y quiere una nueva
versión la ft-ci los estados se
mantuvieron al margen durante años
mientras facebook invirtió miles de
millones de dólares y millones de horas
para hacer de instagram y whatsapp las
aplicaciones que los usuarios disfrutan
hoy ahora la agencia ha anunciado que
ninguna venta será definitiva sin
importar el daño resultante para los
consumidores o el efecto paralizador de
la innovación los medios de comunicación
han planteado los posibles escenarios de
esta batalla legal el sitio web de bears
titula un artículo que en el que dice
que instagram estaría mejor sin facebook
y que si se separa podría deshacerse por
completo de los problemas de su dueño
pero también se pregunta si podría
sobrevivir sin el dinero de facebook que
nunca ha desglosado las finanzas de sus
aplicaciones y no se sabe si la
plataforma es rentable por sí sola el
portal bloomberg dice que disolver
facebook sería más complicado de lo que
parece ya que en lugar de un grupo de
plataformas distintas su dueño mark
zuckerberg esencialmente ha creado
una red masiva con pocas distinciones
entre un usuario de instagram o whatsapp
bajo el mismo argumento el portal market
watch argumenta que el escenario más
probable es que facebook tenga que pagar
una gran multa y el gobierno querrá
revisar cualquier adquisición futura
mientras que el sitio web de noticias
recall propiedad de box dice que una
pregunta aún sin resolver es si las
leyes antimonopolios redactadas hace
décadas están a la altura de la tarea de
regular a las empresas en la era de
internet
las víctimas no sólo enfrentan problemas
dentro de sus países sino con
autoridades extranjeras finalizamos con
noticias que llegan desde europa la
comisión nacional de informática y
libertades de francia impuso multas por
100 millones de euros a google y 35
millones a amazon por infringir las
reglas sobre los rastreadores en línea
conocidos como cookies este organismo
que es el encargado de vigilar la
actividad digital en territorio francés
algo que cuando los usuarios accedían al
dominio de cualquiera de las compañías
ambas se instalaban cookies en sus
dispositivos sin su consentimiento
crítico que tampoco se le ofrecía
información a los usuarios sobre cómo
esas empresas pretendían hacer uso de
estos rastreadores la autoridad les dio
un plazo de tres meses para cambiar sus
políticas o enfrentarían multas de 100
mil euros diarios
hasta aquí y revista digital recuerde
que si quiere repetir esta u otra visión
de nuestro programa lo puede hacer a
través de nuestra página web www puntos
24 punto com
[Música]